[Music]
something
has awoken we've
felt their presence
we know their power
and they're already here
available now with xbox game pass
[Music]
you know action and you love
adventure two a words
from two worlds join forces in
action and adventure
[Music]
huh
a future is not given to you
it is something you must take for
yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
a scrappy team a coach with a troubled
past
across town rivalry will they win the
championship
land the scholarship or set sail
on the greatest ship of all
friendship it's sports
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jordan
[Music]
now say goodbye to adventure dial up the
action
and put a camera in your eyeballs see
the world from the best seat in the
house
just don't look down
fps
[Music]
[Music]
so
legend tells of a genre forged
in fire by ancient forces
heroes embark stats scale
and branching narratives lead to
a bad guy with lots of health it's
role play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you didn't think we'd forget a
post-credit sequence did you
if this doesn't get you hyped i don't
know what will
now available with xbox game pass for pc
e a play
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
what happens next is up to you
if you're only a member of one game pass
this year
make it xbox game pass
or xbox game pass ultimate or xbox game
pass for pc
one of those